well you probably have the sense that
things are out of control on our
southern border and have been since joe
biden was sworn in as president and
you're absolutely right it's worse than
you imagined
a new forecast from princeton policy
advisors projects
1.86 million illegal immigrants crossing
the southern border this year that's the
projection
that'd make this the worst year on
record and of course it would completely
change the united states
forever that's more people than many
states have
many states now how are those migrants
getting here well they're walking across
they're flying from countries all over
the world in order to do that and then
the by demonstration in many cases
is transporting them to other parts of
the country using the u.s
military using air force bases what
they're not doing is moving those
illegal migrants to
aspen or northwest d.c or martha's
vineyard of course not
they're moving him to where you live and
to places that didn't vote for joe biden
of course what is joe biden's response
to this which is
happening that's factual well he just
lied about it
here he is last night we have been able
to move significantly
to change the number there were
thousands of people
in in in custody with the border patrol
it's now cut by ninety percent where
there
is considerably down
so we checked the numbers because we
felt obligated to do that
during this fiscal year which began in
october more than one
million migrants have been apprehended
along our border with mexico those are
just the ones that have been stopped
most of them just kept going of course
a year earlier that number was a hundred
and twenty nine
thousand so you can see that's quite an
increase dominant gotham is the mayor of
the border town of uvalde texas he joins
us to explain what he lives with what
his town lives with
every single day mr mayor thank you so
much for coming on tonight
so that's an enormous number they're
projecting over 1.8
million foreign nationals in one year
all them illegal
you're seeing this up close what does it
look like it's gonna
that number's low in my in my opinion
for what you're seeing you're already at
1.2 million now
so by the end of the year uh i think
you're going to see well over 2 million
in my own personal opinion
so i mean that's just what you're
looking at in the course of one year
is a new country i mean you're looking a
very different united states no one's
going home
everyone's here permanently so the biden
administration is breaking american law
to change the country permanently is it
changing your town
it's changing our town completely i i'll
give you example on
uh just yesterday we had a we
a landowner in town saw a man jump off
the train
in town he walked into our community
he called me i called our police
department chief of police
we stopped the individual he was a cuban
gang member
but he was given his walk-in papers by
border patrol
because the by the administration has
said all cubans are free to go they're
not going to be
uh they're not we're not going to be
detaining them and we're not going to be
sending them back
so we couldn't do anything other than
you know and here he is walking into our
community
and he started out in brockton but wait
a second i mean
i mean cuba is an island that does not
abut
mexico ghana is in africa
haiti is half of hispaniola in the
caribbean i mean it seems like a lot of
people are
flying to mexico to get in to the united
states
that's what we're seeing i mean you've
had i think it's up to 150 countries now
across the border in the del rio sector
uh
you know 150 countries and where do they
how are they getting there
that's you know that's the question i
ask all the time but you can't get an
answer out of the border patrol
and you can't get an answer out of this
administration
i mean you don't live
uvaldi is not a rich community it's a
solid middle class working class
community i've been there
nice people all these people from
foreign countries breaking our laws to
get here and then showered with benefits
from the federal government that your
citizens pay for what do they think of
that
well they're getting frustrated it's
just i mean they're fed up with it
they're tired of it
it's just like the coven situation that
we're facing now
we're being told constantly by this
administration oh social distance where
your mass
get ready for a shutdown don't go here
don't do that stay home
don't go around somebody hadn't been
vaccinated i wish everybody would be
vaccinated but that's their choice
but yet you've got 1.2 million people
who've come across that southern border
they're not telling them oh wait a
minute have you been vaccinated have you
been anything
and this is what we do it seems like
we're giving up our rights as u.s
citizens
to accommodate foreign illegal
immigrants coming into our country
and it's very very frustrating they're
held
so i mean it's it would be a crime for
the citizens of uvalde texas the
americans there to ignore
coronal law but foreign nationals get to
that seems like a double standard
it does well it's just like like you
said earlier in the deal the moment you
crossed that border without coming
through the port of entry
you broke the law you broke the law
you've already broken the law
and so we're going to reward you with a
plane ride
to somewhere in the united states you
know whether it be
chicago whether it be houston whether it
be dallas whether it be austin
san antonio and we're going to give you
a little package with a little money
in it so you can get by in that and then
we're going to then we're going to take
care of you and see that you have this
and see you have that
97 of the people they've released the
united states that had a check-in date
have not checked in 97 yeah
maybe the governor of texas could close
his border using his national guard
maybe he could
maybe grab greg abbott could do
something about this and save save the
country
hoping for that mayor uh john mclaughlin
thank you so much for joining us tonight
appreciate it yes sir thank you i
appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else